where I have a problem with the all-out
libertarian argument of anything goes is
we live in a world where everything you
do affects someone else
I consider this book a media lynching
Nick Bilton bases his so-called true
story on allegations that have never
been proven Lynn Ulbricht is the mother
of Ross Ulbricht
a former Eagle Scout from Austin Texas
and a libertarian idealist who created
the Silk Road an online marketplace on
the dark web that was used to buy drugs
weapons and other illegal goods a
self-taught programmer Albrecht built
this anonymous ecommerce site with the
goal of undermining the drug war by
moving illicit commerce online where the
government would be powerless to stop it
the site was a wild success and Rossum
asked tens of millions of dollars in
Bitcoin operating after an exhaustive
search for his identity by federal law
enforcement agencies Ross was arrested
in San Francisco in 2013 and sentenced
to life without parole he's currently in
the same New York federal prison that
houses the notorious Mexican cartel
kingpin el chapo guzman a new book by
former New York Times columnist and
Vanity Fair special correspondent Nick
Bilton tells the gripping story of a
manhunt for Ross Ulbricht and the so
called Dread Pirate Roberts a pseudonym
used by the Silk Roads chief operator
and a nod to the cult classic The
Princess Bride in which the Dread Pirate
Roberts is a man passed down from one
character to another Nick Bilton has
appointed himself judge jury and
executioner Lynn ohlbrecht maintains
that her son wasn't the Dread Pirate
Roberts a theory that the judge
disallowed in the trial and that builtin
didn't include in the book i sat down
with built him to discuss the book
whether Ross Ulbricht was the only
person to act under the pseudonym Dread
Pirate Roberts
and to get his personal opinion about
his enigmatic protagonist I came at it
from a view point of wanting to
understand how Ross felt and why he
wanted to do this I didn't know if it
was monetary I didn't know if it was
libertarian I didn't know is what it was
and so I really wanted to understand
and that was probably the most important
thing to me in the beginning of this
reporting process he had joined the
libertarian Club in college and he had
libertarian-leaning views prior to that
but at Penn State so I ended up talking
to people who he was in the club with I
talked to people he met at conferences
libertarian conferences I saw some of
the transcription from some of the
debates he done some of the quotes you
give him the local college newspaper and
and spoke to people he had debated with
and and his arguments are incredibly
relatable you know he argued you know
very succinctly okay
why is it the people are thrown in jail
for buying weed or magic mushrooms when
it comes to that I think I completely
agree with Ross and his arguments and
his ideas where I I started to have a
really hard time was with the idea of
selling things like heroin and fentanyl
which have led to more deaths in the
last year alone than people who have
been killed from firearms I don't see
those as drugs I see them as poisons and
one of the things I really tried to do
in the book is I I don't offer a
viewpoint at any point in time what I do
is I tell Ross aside in the chapters
about Ross from his point of view from
the things that I've read and reported
and so on and then I tell the law
enforcement side from that point of view
and of course there's different versions
of the law enforcement side and I want
the reader to decide at the end do they
believe that what Ross did was right
that they believe it was wrong do they
believe drugs should be legal do they
not and and and I really hope that
that's how it comes across you get a
little uncomfortable with things like
heroin or fentanyl being sold on there
and certain people certain characters in
the book also seem uncomfortable with
that who are affiliated with the website
but the other side of that would be well
still better here where there's some
sort of customer review process there's
education happening on the forums to
tell people how to take the drugs more
safely so and also just the side effect
of Prohibition all the violence that
happens just because something that
people want is prohibited in the end how
do you
that all shook out I think that with all
technology and whether it's the Silk
Road Twitter Facebook driverless cars
you name it and with all technology
there is a good side and a bad and and I
think that one of the biggest problems
in Silicon Valley which is something
I've covered for over a decade is that
people never ever think about the bad
they always think about the good and the
bad is something that happens and they
have to kind of clean up the pieces
afterwards for example you know I was
friends with the guys who built some of
the early 3d printers MakerBot and
things like that and I remember saying
what are you going to do with this this
is really cool you can print objects out
and they said oh we're going to make
wall hooks and iPhone cases what was the
first thing that people did was they
built 3d printed guns put aside the
libertarian argument of that whether
guns should be legal or whatever if
there was something that they had
thought about they could have thought
about ways to ensure that a
five-year-old didn't do that or whatever
it is and I think the same thing
happened with the Silk Road you know
there are surveys and studies that came
out in the past few years that have
showed that buying drugs online makes
people feel safer makes them feel like
they're there they know what they're
buying because their review systems all
the things that Ross set out to do but
then there are the negatives and the
negatives are that you know it has
allowed fentanyl to come into the
country more there are other ways that
is come into the country but it's and
people don't understand this is a lab
based heroin that's fifty to a hundred
times stronger and people overdose on it
where I have a problem with the all-out
libertarian argument of anything goes is
we live in a world where everything you
do affects someone else right every
single solitary thing you do has an
effect on another human being and and
the way that I saw Ross arguing it right
was that well that's not my problem the
libertarian viewpoint on the drug war is
that it itself is so harmful that
something has to be done to overturn it
yeah and it's not going to happen
through normal democratic processes it's
been going on for over 40 years
I completely agree a trillion dollars
countless deaths yeah incarceration
completely 1000% agree that the war on
drugs did not work is not working and I
think that what's fascinating is even
the authorities that are chasing Ross in
the book agree you know the de-age and
ends up becoming a bad guy he has a
moment in the story where he's like wait
a second maybe maybe this guy's right
maybe the war on drugs is broken but the
argument that Ross was trying to prove
was that let's just make everything
legal and it will work itself out and I
think that there are a lot of bad people
in the world that try to take advantage
of people by cutting a Parham with rat
poison or whatever it is and and it kind
of doesn't think about the repercussions
of those bad people I want to ask about
the rather large group of federal agents
who hunted down over it yeah that's a
major part of this book about that
manhunt yeah could you just talk about
the size and the scope of the
investigation of Silk Road there's a DEA
team in New York there's an FBI team in
New York there's an IRS agent in New
York there's local police there's people
in in San Francisco that don't even make
it into the story there are people
overseas you know it is everyone is kind
of hunting for this thing because one it
was getting a tremendous amount of
attention in the media because it was
just fascinating this thing existed and
that no one had been caught and hadn't
been shut down and - it's because a lot
of people wanted to be the hero that the
Colby guy but at the same time you see
the dysfunction of government no one
wants to share their information because
they're afraid that if they do someone
will steal it and go and catch this
person they won't get credit there of
course people that do bad things
caryl force the DEA agent who starts
stealing money and selling information
to the Dread Pirate Roberts and all this
insane stuff there's Shawn bridges the
Secret Service guy who does the same
thing and is literally stealing money
it's just mind-boggling just how
dysfunctional this whole thing was
besides you know scrambling just out of
pure ambition and attention media
attention there seems to be at least
with some of these agents almost
ideological motivation I mean we talked
about Ross's ideology his libertarianism
but then there's this homeland security
agent who reads the writings of the
Dread Pirate Roberts which is the
screen name of the administrator of the
Silk Road and you described him as being
terrified at what he's reading could you
talk about the ideological motivations
of some of the people involved in this
for some of the agents for one in
particular Gary alpha from the IRS he
sees the writings of the Dread Pirate
Roberts and they're almost all
incredibly anti-government and he is
working on a task force where there are
people who on 9/11 had had run down to
the buildings and spent weeks down there
trying to trying to pull bodies out of
the rubble and he juxtaposes those two
things and and is livid essentially that
that that these people are now going to
the hospital and some have died because
of what their heroic efforts on 9/11 and
then the Dread Pirate Roberts calling
everyone in the federal government you
know not very nice things I also sent
some of that in the sentencing statement
of the judge in this case whose
statements quite frankly infuriated a
lot of albrecht supporters she gave a
full-throated defense of drug
prohibition
she said that his position was
privileged in the what he did was
terribly destructive to our social
fabric and then I mean threw the book at
him
what do you make of the judges comments
and sentencing in this case well two
things but the first thing I'll say is
that from my reporting Ross was actually
offered a plea deal in the beginning
when he was arrested in New York and the
plea deal was 10 to life and it would
not have charged him with the kingpin
charge which they said okay if you're
going to go to court were throwing the
kingpin charge at you which is which is
everything which is a really bad charge
I will throw in that offering a plea
deal of ten to life is you know I could
see why someone might not I could own
that I can see why someone might not
jump on that but but when the amount of
evidence that was on Ross's computer it
also boggles my mind why he decided to
to take it to court and with the defense
that that he went with he was caught
with 2.1 million words of chat logs on
his laptop photos videos
Spreadsheets all the same stuff was on
thumb drive separately in his computer
there was there is a very difficult case
to argue putting that aside the one of
the toughest questions I've ever asked
around this book is if I agree with the
sentencing and I can see it from both
points of view I can see people who look
at it and say it it's ridiculous it's
two life sentences plus 40 years for
running this website and I completely
understand that argument it makes
complete sense the other point of view
is that there were at least six people
who overdosed and died as a result of
the site that got bad drugs or had a bad
reaction you can say that the murders
didn't happen but but he thought that
there they were happening and the
argument from that side is well of
course that was a just sentence as far
as what the judge said and this is one
of the things that really upsets me the
most about this whole story you know
this is a judge who not only hears cases
like Ross Ulbricht but hears cases every
single day from people in the Bronx and
elsewhere that sell drugs because they
don't really have many options and I
what I took from her statement that it
was a privileged argument is that Ross
had a very lucky upbringing he had a
family loved him he had a lot of
opportunities he went to school for to
be a physicist and he chose to go down
this path for the reasons he chose to go
down and his argument that it was
different because it was from behind a
computer I think was what frustrated her
the most and what frustrates me the most
is you have everyone out there defending
Ross and and and but I don't see anyone
out there defending all these poor
people who who are in jail for selling
weed or magic mushrooms who are African
American Hispanics someone like Ross who
basically devoted his life to trying to
stop the drug war yeah I'm happening and
the people who support him who deeply
believe that the drug war is immoral and
wrong think that this was a tool that
could have dis
arrested that obviously they wanted to
set an example of this guy who who tried
to do something to end this unjust drug
war that throws all these poor people
with these crazy sentences to hear a
federal judge who hands out those
sentences sanctimoniously lecturing I
think probably rubs people the wrong way
I cannot speak for the judge I am NOT
the judge if I was the judge it probably
would have been a different sentence
definitely would've been a different
sentence but the everything goes
mentality had repercussions I don't
agree with the sentencing for these mile
drugs I do not believe that they should
be they should be illegal I really think
it's just ridiculous but when I see the
results I mean go look go read the
series in the Washington Post of people
who have overdosed from fentanyl and
look at some of the stories and the
videos of kids whose parents have died
from it
it is harrowing that shouldn't be legal
as far as I'm concerned
like in my personal opinion the argument
for making something like heroin or even
fentanyl legal would be that at least if
it's out in the open we can treat the
terrible consequences the public health
consequences more effectively than when
it's totally underground and again that
something like the Silk Road would be a
kind of crowbar to you know pry
legalization open blocks I'm curious do
you believe that it should be legal do
you believe that these that heroin the
fence and all that that all these things
should just be kind of open and and I
believe in harm reduction I don't think
that harm elimination is realistic but I
think that making everything legal makes
it a lot easier for information about
these things to get out there and for
treatment programs but I also believe
that there that there are certain things
that do you believe cyanide should be
legal I see I personally see fentanyl
and heroin is the same thing it's it's
not these are not these are not drugs
that we should be taking I mean
you tens of thousands of people now died
a year from those drugs in a world where
drugs were totally legal who knows
fentanyl would even exist yeah I mean I
can see that I just I think that I'm
again like for me it's not all or
nothing I do believe it but literally
just boggles my mind that the magic
mushrooms are illegal and that even weed
is illegal and MDMA and all these things
I just just I don't understand it
doesn't make no sense but when it comes
to these hard drugs that people overdose
from on a daily basis if not an hourly
basis I just don't understand what why
they exist and I and I don't think that
we should be encouraging people to to
take them obviously Ross is a
sympathetic character to someone like me
in a lot of ways but there's one area of
this story that even makes his
supporters uncomfortable which is the
supposed murder for hire that happen
there was one that was completely staged
by a DEA agent the one who was siphoning
bitcoins off the site yeah there were
supposedly five others that were the
Hells Angels were maybe contracted or
maybe it was some sort of scam in any
case no bodies ever came up and it was
not ever used in court against Albrecht
well I was using court against Albrecht
he was not charged with murder but the
kingpin charge he that was used both at
the trial chat logs rounded discussions
around it and it was used a lot in the
sentencing couldn't you make the
argument that that's worse in a way you
know bringing it up in the trial but not
actually you know feeling like you have
enough evidence to charge him so you're
what I can tell from the reporting I've
done people have spoken to they didn't
not charge the murders because they
didn't have the evidence for the murders
they would never have charged him with
murder they would have charged him with
some sort of commissioning - to have
someone killed or something like that
which is also a federal crime but the
reason is is because they wanted to
prove a point about the website and that
was why they went after that kingpin
charge from what I can tell the point
was if you run a website like this that
these are going to be the repercussions
for those actions that was the
government point of view I'm not
I agree with it I'm just saying that
that's what that's what I heard during
my reporting and there's been some
criticism of the book from Russell
Brooks mother Lynn who's a very
outspoken advocate she's called the book
a media lynching and says that you
basically just presented the government
side of the case Nick Bilton has
appointed himself judge jury and
executioner especially in relation to
these Commission murder charges where
the defense side of the argument is that
the Dread Pirate Roberts who was the
administrator who ran the site might
have been Ross at one point but see
along the way it was a right heel by
that why don't you buy that well first
of all do you read the book do you think
it's a one-sided point of view from the
government side I don't think that but
you don't raise this possibility that
there might have been other people
behind the DPR account because there
wasn't there is not a shred of shred of
a doubt in my mind that Ross ran outside
from day one the evidence it is
overwhelming and I don't need the
government to tell me that I went
through everything I went through 2.1
million words of chat logs we went
through social media posts photos videos
you know Ross in college arguing these
things saying the same exact things in
college during debate class as the Dread
Pirate Roberts said throughout the
entire lifecycle of the site if you want
to argue that the chat logs were were
were hacked and changed you would need a
team of a thousand people to pull that
off imagine all you did for three years
was with was talk online and you didn't
really have many conversations in person
now imagine that you at the same time as
talking online to your to your
co-workers you're also posting on social
media about things right so let's just
say I have a few minutes while you're in
the library and I hack into your
computer and I'm going to place some
documents there right how the heck am I
going to get the to date to the the
minute when you're on a flight telling
your employees that I'm going to be on a
flight when you're camping saying I'm
going to be away this weekend when
you're you meet a girl telling people
you just met a girl to pull those things
off and to manipulate his social media
it's in
it would be impossible if you read the
book and you see how much of a mess the
government was while trying to hunt this
thing down if you believe that the
government could pull off manipulating
all that stuff to throw this random kid
in jail
it's beyond delusional what does it
necessarily prove that there were not
other people with access to the login
because what one of the main alternative
theories out there was that mark carp
Ellis who founded the Bitcoin exchange
mount GOx whose assets were seized in
another investigation leading up to this
might have been the Dread Pirate Roberts
oh you're trying to tell me that mark
carp Ellis put together manipulated
those chat logs over almost three years
manipulated his social media feed his
emails his text messages the photos
right then not only that took the entire
Silk Road that was the exact version
that's on the laptop knocking to Ross's
bedroom and put the thumb drives next to
his bedside at the same day he's
arrested and managed to get all those
files on his computer in a library in a
matter of about four or five minutes
it's impossible and so I just don't
believe for any moment that there was
more than one Dread Pirate Roberts
I just don't there's nothing that
implies that other than the fact of that
brilliant name the Dread Pirate Roberts
the defense is working on an appeal
right now for us and a couple of the
things they've revealed are that they
say they've discovered some deleted
conversations between the Dread Pirate
Roberts and someone who might have been
another corrupted agent and
investigation they also say they that
someone seems to have logged into the
DPR account after a lot of DPR formica
not the DPR account someone logged into
the DPR account they would have taken
off all the money and run away someone
logged into the DPR form account and
from what I understand it was about
seven weeks after the and he and it was
it was when the employees were taking
the code from the site to build the Silk
Road to and amid the code was a DPR
Forum login given the complexities of
this investigation and the nature of
online identities and
some of these anomalies you still don't
think there's any room for any
uncertainty or doubt as to who was
exactly behind the DPR account at all
time I just don't have a shred of a
doubt that it was Roth when you read the
chat logs from the point in time when he
supposedly and a lot of someone else
there's no differentiation between them
before and after and the social media
post and so on when I first started
writing this book I thought there were
multiple Dread Pirate Roberts I
literally when I first sat down and I
started writing this book I was like
okay my job was to try to figure out who
they are and then I saw the evidence and
I saw the Diaries on his computer and
even before I saw the chat logs and it
was just it it just it was the beginning
of a bullet train that started to point
in one direction and given the
corruption that we know was involved
with this case from people like Carl for
census you don't have any doubts about
anything being falsified in there I
believe that they were predict there
were things were falsified from from
call forces DEA reports I'm sure he was
not a not a very honest person but I
don't believe that anyone got into
office computer and managed to put in
thousands and thousands of documents
related to the Silk Road I part of me
that wishes that really really wishes
Ross would have said I did this I
believe that the war on drugs is stupid
and wrong and I did it because I believe
this and become a martyr for them for
the cause the other part of this was so
fascinating to me is the technological
part you know I meet people that will
say on Twitter or Facebook you're a
piece of [ __ ] and go to hell and this
that and the other I'll meet them in
person and they're the nicest sweetest
person in the world we have a
disassociation with what technology does
and and how it disconnects us from human
beings and even at loss of sentencing he
apologized for the things that had
happened after the parents of the people
who had died stood up and spoke he says
that he didn't intend for any of this to
happen I want to finish talking about
intentions versus reality because you
make it very clear in the book
that he did start out with the idea of
like I want my legacy to be the person
who began the end of the war on drugs
the Silk Road is gone it's been taken
down but as we know dozens of you know
haters have popped up in its wake
what do you think his legacy will be and
what will people have learned from the
Ross Ulbricht case his legacy will be
both good and both that I think that
there will be a group of people mostly
the people watching this who will see
that he has it not started the
conversation about how technology can be
used to fight the war on drugs will
argue that and we'll see that from that
point of view and you can't deny that
but then there's the other side of it
and that there are people who have
spoken to who say that that these online
drug market places whether it's the Silk
Road or others that are out there have
helped lead to the rise in fentanyl in
America which is helping to the opioid
epidemic not exclusively but have helped
and that and there were repercussions
for for legalizing drugs on the dark web
where there are still bad things that
happen and I think that I see from my
own personal point of view Rob that
legacy is being both a good one end and
a bad one
you
[Music]
you